[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll get some more phone calls coming
up we make way for the hall of famer jim
gray he is the co-host of the great
podcast the let's go podcast alongside
tom brady and larry fitzgerald jim how
are you today
i'm great dan how are you doing great i
was curious your approach to tom brady
when you interview him as opposed to
another
subject
well i've interviewed tom brady probably
750 to a thousand times
so there's a total familiarity
we've been doing this show for more than
a decade um so as opposed to another
athlete
there's a lack of familiarity
and
we're not doing a show together
but when you when you sense something as
good a reporter as you are when you hear
something
you would normally pounce on that
how do you approach that if you sense
something with tom
and you know the the approach of uh
pouncing on it and and realizing that
maybe there's uh kind of breadcrumbs
there for a bigger topic
well we have much more time we have 25
minutes a show and 45 minutes for the
podcast
so it's it's not like me doing the end
of a game interview where i have to get
right to it because we're rushing off to
you know the tonight show
or sports center or whatever so you have
two questions and you're done so you
can't you can't have a conversation with
somebody you can't elicit more
information you can't have a you know
there's no comfort there you got a boom
boom boom so it's just a lot different
format so uh pouncing on something isn't
uh isn't necessary
take me back to that weekend when uh
chefter and jeff darlington reported
over the weekend i think it was saturday
at 2 30 eastern that tom was uh you know
going to retire
you tape the podcast then on monday
correct okay
so how do you
do you discuss topics give me let us
behind the scenes there of what you do
in preparing for that with tom and larry
and that topic that weekend
i was in mexico that weekend and my
phone was blowing up and i hadn't heard
from tom
and so
um
i didn't know anything about it
and i don't know if i'm 10th on the list
dan or if i'm 20th or 50th or 100 but
i'm on the list
somewhere at some point
he would have reached out and says
jim i'm out
uh
i'll talk to you later or whatever it
would have been i didn't get that so
uh
i called tom's agent and he didn't know
anything about it
i spoke to mr and mrs brady and they
didn't know anything about it they had
just spoke to tom and tom said that
wasn't the case so
we've been involved with each other for
a long time tom and i doing this show i
always take tom at his word because tom
is tom's word is really good so we
approached the show on on that monday
which was a couple of days later and i
asked him what he was doing and he said
he hadn't decided yet
so
you know
it's this isn't a show where you're
supposed to badger somebody he's it's
he's the co-host of the show you're not
hitting him over the head and it's his
decision and his life and when he came
to that decision with his life uh he
would inform us
what did you uh think when you heard on
tuesday or you saw this social media
that tom was retiring
not that he decided to retire and that
he decided over the course of time with
gisele and whoever else was involved
with the decision jack benny and vivi uh
that it was time time to do that by the
way dan the club also hadn't been
informed so uh jason and
bruce aryans and and the glazer family
none of them knew and i believe they
released a statement to that effect and
saying tom had told them that that
wasn't the case so i guess the tuesday
morning whatever it was 12 or 14 hours
after we did the show
that's what he had decided to do and
wrote out his uh
uh his instagram
when
it feels like people are still don't
believe it's real
do you believe it's real
i do
i do but i also believe that he doesn't
know if and when that urge will come
back so i think he answered the question
you know to the best of his ability and
and really honestly when he said you
know never say never because he's been
doing this for 30 plus years and he's
not leaving dan because there's anything
physically wrong he led the league in
every statistical category for a
quarterback so it's more of an emotional
thing perhaps that he'll be 45 and
doesn't want to get pounced on by von
miller and aaron donald and these guys
but i truly believe that if he wanted to
play physically he could continue to
play at a very very high level and he's
even said that probably well beyond next
year if that's what he decided more
likely to play again tom or larry
fitzgerald
oh tom
larry had no interest in coming back at
all
no
well larry larry larry made that
decision he never turned in his
retirement papers but larry never
wavered larry had calls every week
from
great teams that really wanted him and
could have played probably on a
championship team
and he just he just never even looked
back he never thought about it he was
enjoying his life he was going to his
kids of flag football games he's very
involved in a number of businesses he's
a really philanthropic guy he was nfl
man of the year
larry larry had decided that that was it
when antonio brown goes awol did tom try
to talk larry fitzgerald into playing
for the buccaneers
not that i'm aware of no and larry and
tom have not told me that so no
tom knew where larry was uh
they were around each other last summer
quite a bit uh a number of times so
uh tom didn't waste his time on that
call is the podcast on hiatus
podcast
was our last podcast
on sirius was monday night and we'll
come back in august and both tom and
larry and i we're all set to go for the
next football season and
series has been a great partner and
we'll have some more fun yeah i was
wondering about that people jumped on
that they're like it's on hiatus until
you know september
and then it was like oh
september that means maybe tom's gonna
come back and i thought well they're not
gonna talk football
during the off season i guess and you
guys will just pick it up when you get
ready to start the season
correct i mean we don't
that that that's been normal what we've
done we've done this show for more than
a decade and so you know we but we don't
do it all year we don't come on and
start talking about the final four and
the masters in baseball
i'd be curious
i'd be curious about it because you know
larry fitzgerald
a really good golfer you get their
comments on augusta i'm fine with that
march madness as well
maybe we'll do a special maybe we'll
jump over from the mad dog channel over
to the dan patrick channel and maybe
we'll do a summer special
when did it start to click where tom
brady and you became
friends not reporter and uh or partners
i guess um
do you remember
well
i had just asked him don shula used to
do monday night football with me on on
westwood one
and uh
he decided that he had had enough
that it was just you know too much and i
believe at the time
don was maybe 80 years old 79 or 80
years old so this was 12 years ago or so
and uh so i just happened to run in i
ran into thomas
he was watching his son jack play play
uh tennis
at riviera
and jack at the time was maybe three or
two years old three years old four years
old really just a youngster playing
playing tennis i said hey
do you by chance have any interest in
doing monday night football on the radio
with me
because i had known he'd done a local
show with weei
in in boston every monday and he said
well what does it entail and i told him
he said well why don't you write write
my agents what exactly it is you have my
number and we'll just stay in touch well
a couple weeks later he he got back in
touch with me he said that he had just
spoken to a don yi and steve dubin said
yeah i'd like to do that then he wrote
me a letter dan before we started our
first monday night uh thing he said
you'll get the same effort out of me on
monday nights that i give my teammates
on sunday afternoon
and i still have that letter and you
know what he has he's he hasn't missed a
show even when he's played on monday
nights he's taped it early and he's been
he's just been terrific he's a better
human being than he is a quarterback
if you had to bet on what he's going to
do
next next chapter could you see him
being in the media
aside from the podcast
i was going to say he's with us of
course he is of course he is i had to
catch myself i don't i don't personally
see that i'm sorry i didn't hear you no
no i i said i i threw in the podcast
they're late knowing that you would pick
up on that so obviously uh but see could
you see him doing a network thing a
manning cast amazon
i don't want to speak for tom
but every every indication that i have
would indicate no
might he do some more specials might he
do you know another man in the arena or
a documentary or appear from time to
time he's appeared on the manning cast
he might do something like that but i
don't think he's going to try and do
something like tony rome or troy
i could see him in gronk doing a manning
cast type
something on amazon what do you think
that'd be fun it's a good idea
uh but i think gronk's gonna play oh you
do
i do
with champion
tom said tom said a couple days ago on
our final show that he hoped gronk's
play that he's got a lot left in the
tank that he'll make any team a whole
lot better uh that he still has
championship football in him
and that he would you know hate to see
him go
at this point but would totally respect
whatever he wanted to do
it's jim gray hall of famer the podcast
uh let's go with tom brady and larry
fitzgerald on hiatus until uh
august
uh
who's the athlete you haven't
interviewed
that you want to
i've interviewed everybody i've wanted
to interview i guess babe ruth but
unfortunately that's not going to occur
that's not going to happen
uh
i'm not i'm not sitting here you know
uh
thinking that i've that i'm lacking
anything or or that there's anybody who
i really you know i'm still curious i'd
like to interview i guess i'd like to
interview otani because he's great uh
i'm sure there's a language barrier and
it can be translated but i think he's a
great athlete so i guess that would be
the answer
can you see lebron staying and playing
with his son the important event yes
yes i do
i think that is important to him i think
he's kind of stated that i think it
would be you know it would be a lot of
fun to see i think lebron can still play
at a high level i don't know where he'll
be in a couple of years or what that
team would look like and how exactly
that would work and if his son you know
we're taking into account that his son
brawny is good enough to play in the nba
now maybe somebody will do it for the
novelty of it
uh even if he's not good enough but i
think he has a long way to go you know
in his development but i wonder if
lebron looks at this and gets into an
organ i i don't know if he ends his
career with the lakers
what do you think i don't either
i don't either you know it's it's also
transient now and everybody just kind of
comes and goes i mean look at james
harden three teams in a year james
harden is
great an offensive force in the history
of the nba as we've ever seen
and you know
he's just
kevin durant the best player in the nba
look at look at this now and we spend
more time
wondering where these guys are going to
be then we actually do paying attention
it's like its own it's not even a hot
stove league it's just like constantly
burning it's like one of these wildfires
unfortunately that we have here in
california so all this speculation is
going to go on and on so i could see
lebron playing someplace else if that
meant he could play with brownie did you
save your interview notes from uh
lebron's decision night
i probably have him somewhere
i'll be curious here are the interview
notes dan right here
there was just this season with let's go
which you were a part of yeah
so yeah i probably have them somewhere i
still go back to that question i ask and
and i did follow up with you when i
talked to tom about that poll that you
feel with your family that i felt when i
was at espn and i left at 50 and here's
tom at 44.
and i i followed up with you and you
were kind enough to share that you know
you could tell that maybe it kind of hit
tom in a different way because
everything else was football related and
i went family related
did you glean anything from that answer
from tom that maybe you didn't realize
at the time of what he might be really
feeling
well i thought it was a great question
by you and i don't say that because
we're friends or because this is your
show so it's a lousy question i tell you
you stink that was a great question but
i also know how tom feels about his
family and there's there's a spot that
it touches uh whether it's his parents
and his sisters who were so important to
him or whether it's benny jack vivian
giselle
you know when he goes there
it brings out an emotion and he wants to
be with his son and his son's in new
york and so when you ask that question i
knew how he felt and i know how it
bothers him and i know he wants to spend
more time
so i could see that it touched him and
everybody else did kind of focus on
some of the other things there was that
young man who was in the stands that
also touched him
held up that sign about cancer and
saving his life and inspiring him uh so
i could see you know tom's an emotional
guy and he's a real guy and and he
really really cares he cares deeply
about football cares about people he
wants to see his teammates succeed he
doesn't feel in any way that ripping
somebody else somehow enhances him
so he's tried to inspire and lift people
so when you talked about his family that
took him to a place you know where he
wants to be
his social media is unbelievable
i i don't know
i would love to have had that social
media with the patriots but
why did tom all of a sudden go unplugged
here with the buccaneers
well there's a different atmosphere and
there's different folks and tom has
tremendous respect and reverence for his
time
at the patriots and he's grateful
but those folks are are tightly wound
it's a whole it's a whole different you
know bruce arians is out having fun on
the golf course and once in a while once
in a while he may have you know an adult
beverage and
it's a little it's a it's just a little
looser atmosphere so tom could be
more of himself and and you know tom
wanted to follow tom's a great teammate
so tom wanted to follow what it was the
protocols were and coach belichick just
wasn't going to have that and didn't
want that and here
he could be more of himself and
that's all much more permissible and
part of the program have you had
belichick on the let's go podcast
we have not but we haven't requested him
either oh we haven't asked him
you gotta have him on
well maybe next year you know if tom's
out of football perhaps perhaps
now he asked for coach belichick a
number of times on monday night football
and he wasn't available but he was
available at super bowls and he and he
and he did come on and answer the
questions and he's always to me he's
always very courteous very nice very
respectful um and uh obviously he's he's
the greatest coach uh probably in the
history of the nfl with the exception of
the numbers and i'll go with don shula
because he has 347 but i think coach
belichick is going to stick around until
he breaks that record i agree
hey great to talk to you sorry i didn't
uh get a chance to do a drive by there
in los angeles
dan i'm sorry i missed you next time my
house how's your pursuit of the corn
fairy tour going uh it's good i i'm uh
i'm taking a couple of weeks off for the
corn ferry golf tour but uh you know i'm
not ready for riviera let's put it that
way
well the pros are this week so tune in
should be fun thank you bud
thanks dan thanks for having me on jim
gray hall of famer and uh co-host of
let's go podcast with tom brady and
larry fitzgerald